liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz zu wo ohne lage
dazu begrüße ich ganz herzlich den
geschäftsführenden bundes gesundes
gesundheitsminister jens spahn herzlich
willkommen und professor dr lothar
wieler den präsidenten des
robert-koch-instituts auch als sie ein
herzliches willkommen schön dass sie
hier sind obwohl glücklich wir uns alle
wünschen dass solche pressekonferenzen
jetzt nicht mehr stattfinden müssen
bevor wir anfangen eine kurze
vorbemerkung weil mehrere sender auch
live übertragen die
bundespressekonferenz ist keine
institution der bundesregierung sondern
ein unabhängiger verein von
journalistinnen und journalisten die aus
berlin berichten unsere aufgabe ist es
pressekonferenzen zu veranstalten damit
unsere mitgliedschaft die öffentlichkeit
besser informieren kann das als
vorbemerkung und jetzt ersparen sie an
das wort
jahrzehnte waren die meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren die lage ist
weiterhin ernst ernster auch als letzter
woche dynamik ist ungebrochen allein in
den letzten vier wochen hat sich die
inzidenz verfünffacht innerhalb von vier
wochen verfünffacht das
infektionsgeschehen mit rekord
insolvenzen auch in den letzten tagen
und wir sehen natürlich dann auch in der
folge auf den intensivstationen in den
krankenhäusern bei den todeszahlen
wieder traurig hohe werte es ist zehn
nach zwölf und auch wenn wir sehen dass
die lage in deutschland unterschiedlich
ist dass es in den unterschiedlichen
regionen wenn sie nach
schleswig-holstein schauen oder nach
bayern noch unterschiedlichem
infektionsgeschehen der belastungen der
krankenhäuser ist ist auch genauso klar
wir sind in einer nationalen notlage die
auch eine gemeinsame nationale
kraftanstrengung braucht das braucht
auch
gemeinsame staatliches entschlossenes
handeln um diese dynamik zu brechen die
werkzeuge dazu sind da impfen testen aha
regeln schutzmasken oder eben vor allem
auch kontakt reduzierung dafür war der
gestrige tag wie neben der entscheidung
im deutschen bundestag vor allem auch
das treffen von bund und ländern die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
sie wissen ich hätte sie mir auch schon
drei wochen früher gewünscht und drei
wochen früher auch einen unterschied zu
machen aber nun ist es gut dass die
stattgefunden hat die wahrheit ist
alleine mit impfen mit postern werden
wir das brechen der welle dass wir jetzt
kurzfristig brauchen nicht mehr
erreichen es braucht also maßnahmen der
kontakt beschränke und dafür haben wir
uns gestern auf ein regelwerk einigen
können dass eben ab einer bestimmten aus
vitalisierung des instituts also bei
einer bestimmten belastungssituation im
jeweiligen bundesland zweig im nächsten
schritt zweig plus in einem weiteren
schritt zusätzliche maßnahmen der
kontakt beschränkung greifen sollen aus
meiner sicht auch greifen müssen es geht
dabei vor allem auch um einen lock down
für ungeimpfte in einem ersten schritt
also deutliche kontakt beschränkung dort
für ein solches regelwerk das über 3g
als grund maßnahme für herbst und winter
hinaus es klare kriterien gibt inzidenz
und oder hospitalisierung bezogen für 2g
und weitere schritte haben wir schon im
juli in einem bericht des
bundesministeriums geworben haben auch
dafür geworden ist im august in die
bund- länder- ergebnisse mit
hineinzunehmen es ist gut dass es jetzt
gemeinsam ist einheitliches vorgehen im
bund zwischen bund und ländern dafür
gibt jetzt es ist wichtig dass auch
konsequent umzusetzen
und vor allem auch konsequent zu
kontrollieren
dass die maßnahmen auch eingehalten
werden weil ein zweites thema ansprechen
dass die schwierige situation deutlich
macht dass gestern auch eine rolle
gespielt hat in der öffentlichen
wahrnehmung noch nicht so sehr das ist
die notwendigkeit von verlegungen von
intensivpatienten und patienten im
krankenhaus innerhalb von regionen sie
wissen sie haben deutschland in einem
sogenannten kleeblatt in fünf
unterschiedliche regionen aufgeteilt
innerhalb derer verlegt wird von einem
krankenhaus zum nächsten rennen eben
eine entsprechende belastungssituation
entsteht hat noch sehr vor augen die
zahl von 3 prozent freien intensivbetten
in münchen zum beispiel letzte woche
drei prozent ist faktisch nichts sie
müssen sehen es gibt nicht wenige
intensivstationen in deutschland die
haben fünf zehn oder fünfzehn
intensivbetten man denkt dann zehn
prozent das klingt doch wie viel aber
natürlich es zehn prozent von zehn
betten offensichtlich ein bett das dann
auch der jeweiligen intensivstation noch
frei ist ein schlaganfall ein
herzinfarkt eine unvorhergesehene
situation und es wird sehr sehr
schwierig und deswegen ist eben das
verlegen idealerweise auch das
frühzeitige verlegen von risikopatienten
wichtig warum frühzeitig wenn erst mal
jemand an der eco ist in der beratung
ist ist natürlich auch vom aufwand her
die verlegung in ein anderes krankenhaus
oder gar in eine andere region viel viel
größer und wir kommen in eine situation
wo wir wohl auch erstmalig in größerem
umfang werden nicht nur innerhalb eines
hebels einer region sondern überregional
in deutschland patientinnen und
patienten verlegen müssen möglicherweise
auch ins benachbarte ausland dazu gibt
es enge und länder abstimmung jede woche
ein drittes thema das sich ansprechen
möchte ist die frage des impfens und vor
allem der auffrischimpfung das boostern
wie gesagt das ist wichtig ist es auch
wichtig um die welle die dynamik unter
kontrolle zu bekommen aber es bricht es
sie eben nicht kurzfristig das ist auch
wichtig zu sehen was wir dort sehen ist
dass das tempo deutlich zunimmt wir
haben letzte woche vier millionen
impfdosen bestellt worden sind die wir
ausgeliefert haben diese woche vier
nächste woche über sechs millionen
impfdosen die ausgeliefert werden die
bestellt worden sind von den arztpraxen
von den impfzentren von den impfenden
stellen in deutschland
ja eine zeit wo nur noch 20.000
arztpraxen teilgenommen haben an den
impfungen im niedergelassenen bereich
das war im sommer als die zahlen
insgesamt zurückgegangen sind wir haben
mittlerweile wieder über 45.000
arztpraxen die sich gegenwärtig an den
auffrischimpfungen und den impfungen
beteiligen und sehen auch hier eine
weiter anwachsende zahl sie erinnern
sich höchst in den höchstzeiten hatten
wir 75.000
arztpraxen ärztinnen und ärzte die
mitgemacht haben also auch dort die
tendenz klar in die richtige richtung
wir hatten vorletzte woche eine million
impfdosen die von den arztpraxen
bestellt worden sind für nächste woche
sind es fünf millionen impfdosen die die
arztpraxen bestellt haben wir sehen also
dass das tempo deutlich zulegt wir haben
stand heute morgen 5,2 millionen
auffrischimpfungen deutschland 15
prozent der über 60 jährigen haben eine
solche erhalten aber es reicht eben noch
nicht wir brauchen und das war auch
gestern richtig in der vereinbarung von
bund und ländern ein noch größeres tempo
auch bei den auffrischimpfungen sein
letzten dienst aber diesen letzten
dienstag dieser woche ist die vergütung
ja durch eine verordnung die ich
gezeichnet habe erhöht von 20 auf 28
euro für jede kurve neun zehn impfungen
am wochenende auf 36 euro für jede kurve
neun zehn impfungen um den zusätzlichen
aufwand den die arztpraxen haben auch in
der umstellung in den abläufen in dem
was es auch jetzt wieder auch an
nachfragen durch patientinnen und
patienten gibt abzubilden wir haben
vereinbart dass die impfzentren bis ende
mai mindestens durch den bund finanziert
werden die länder haben darauf
hingewiesen dass wenn man personal
gewinnen will und halten will für die im
zentrum eben auch längerfristige
verträge natürlich wichtig sind deswegen
bis ende mai und ich will auch
ausdrücklich sagen dass wir stärker
werden auch jetzt eine zeitlang
impfstoff von moderner für die booster
impfung nutzen von diesen haben wir viel
rauch vorrätig zudem finde ich auch
richtig impfstoff so zu nutzen dass
keiner verfällt auch das müssen wir gut
aus steuern beide impfstoffe bei montech
wie moderne gleich gut geeignet zur
auffrischimpfung und jetzt wird eben bei
den auffrischimpfungen auch moderner in
den nächsten wochen wieder eine etwas
größere rolle spielen abschließend meine
damen und herren das war eine woche der
entscheidung seien letzten samstag
kostenlose bürger tests wieder verfügbar
am dienstag die impfverordnung mit der
vergütung für die ärzte die finanzierung
der impfzentren gestern die entscheidung
im deutschen bundestag für die
rechtlichen grundlagen für das handeln
der länder und der behörden vor ort die
ministerpräsidenten-konferenz gestern
nach heute der bundesrat nach diesen
entscheidungen geht es jetzt darum das
auch umzusetzen und zu leben in
entschlossenem staatlichen handelns aber
das ist eben auch an uns gerichtet an
alle bürgerinnen und bürger natürlich
auch im verantwortlichen handeln jedes
einzelnen das gilt seit 18 monaten dass
das zusammenkommen muss entschlossen
dass staatliches handeln und das handeln
jedes einzelnen im alltag
ich weiß dass viele das auch tun das
impfen ist das testen ist das
aufeinander aufpassen ich weiß aber auch
dass mindestens genauso viele ist leid
sind wir alle hatten gehofft durch die
impfung auf einen anderen winter müssen
aber eben feststellen durch die delta
variante und die zu große zahl an
ungeimpften dass wir wieder in einer
schwierigen wenn nicht sogar in der
schwersten lage sind in dieser pandemie
das fällt schwer das tut weh das
frustriert aber es nützt alles nächstes
ist so und deswegen geht es darum auch
jetzt gut aufeinander aufzupassen sich
zu schützen im alltag durch masken aha
regeln vor allem aber eben auch durch
impfung schützen sie sich und andere
herzlichen dank erspart professor jürgen
tag meine damen und herren wir haben in
deutschland zurzeit 110 landkreise mit
einer 7 tages inzidenz ab 500 das sind
inzwischen über ein viertel aller
landkreis wir haben inzwischen auch
zwölf landkreise mit einer inzidenz von
über 1000 es gibt zurzeit geschätzt mehr
als eine halbe millionen aktive kurve 19
fälle in unserem land das sind so viele
wie noch nie und bei kindern im alter
von 5 bis 14 da liegt die inzidenz bei
über 700 die zahl der schul ausbrüche
steigt ebenfalls es geht hier schon
lange nicht mehr um einzelne
ausbruchsgeschehen ganz deutschland ist
ein einziger großer ausbruch das ist
eine nationale notlage wir müssen jetzt
die notbremse ziehen deutschland
befindet sich bereits in der höchsten
stufe des kontroll kowitz stufenkonzept
ist das ist die stufe 2 bei allen drei
leitindikatoren sind die schwellenwert
überschritten die bundesweite 7 tages
inzidenz ist inzwischen bei weit über
300 die sieben tage hospitalisierung
inzidenz hat in dieser woche bundesweit
den von uns vorgeschlagenen
schwellenwert von 5 überschritten sie
liegt bei 5,3 und von allen bundesweit
betreibt barren betten auf
intensivstationen sind bereits 15
prozent mit 19 patienten belegt der von
uns vorgeschlagene schwellenwert liegt
bei 12 prozent
das ist wie gesagt der bundesdeutsche
durchschnitt aber in vielen regionen
sind die krankenhäuser intensivstation
natürlich tatsächlich am anschlag die
medizinische versorgung ist dort zum
teil nicht mehr gewährleistet das kann
auch bedeuten dass auch andere patienten
im zweifelsfall eben nicht mehr optimal
versorgt werden menschen mit
schlaganfall zum beispiel bei menschen
die einen unfall hatte die todesfälle
mit kuwait 19 steigen wieder rasant an
wir bekommen bereits jetzt schon an
vielen tagen zwischen 200 und 300
todesfälle übermittelt das ist die
situation heute und wir rechnen damit
dass sie sich in ganz deutschland auch
weiter zuspitzt
wir müssen einfach kinder und ältere
menschen schützen wir sind leider an
einem punkt angelangt an dem wir viel
krankheit und leid gar nicht mehr
verhindern können trotzdem haben wir es
zum großen teil immer noch selbst in der
hand wie schlimm diese situation in der
zukunft noch wird und vor allem wie
lange sie noch anhält wir müssen jetzt
das ruder herumreißen wir dürfen
wirklich keine zeit verlieren das ist
wie bei einem tanker der auf eine
hafenmauer zufährt der tanker ist erst
mal in bewegung wenn wir sofort mit
aller kraft gegen steuern dann wird er
noch eine weile weiter fahren und die
hafenmauer vielleicht noch seitlich
rahmen er wird aber hoffentlich nicht
mehr frontal
wir alle können und müssen jetzt
gegensteuern
impfungen und die dritte impfung meine
damen und herren sind natürlich enorm
wichtig geimpfte erkranken deutlich
seltener symptomatisch & co wird neu
sind und sie müssen auch deutlich
seltener ins krankenhaus wir haben dazu
in unserem wochenbericht er jeden
donnerstag heraus kommen also gestern
grafiken für die verschiedenen
altersgruppen veröffentlicht die sehr
eindrücklich sind hier ist eine grafik
sind die 18 bis 59 jahren und sie sehen
auf der linken seite die symptomatischen
patienten mit cupid 19 infektionen auf
der rechten seite die hospitalisierten
fälle mit 19 infektion die gestrichelte
linie meine damen kann die obere das
sind die ungeimpften
die untere linie sind gegeben man sieht
ja deutlich den unterschied die
impfungen wirken sehr sehr gut
also wir müssen jetzt die impflücken
schließen auch zweig ist wichtig aber in
der aktuellen situation reicht das
leider nicht mehr wir brauchen jetzt
zusätzlich eine massive kontakt
reduktion um die ausbreitung des virus
zu verlangsamen dazu gehört zb gemäß den
vorschlag vorschlägen von kontroll co
wird in stufe 2 wenn möglich zu hause
bleiben
großveranstaltungen absagen personenzahl
bei kleineren veranstaltungen reduzieren
hotspots wie schlecht belüftete basen
clubs schließen dazu gehört auch dass
wir alle unsere privaten kontakte so
weit wie möglich reduzieren und wir
sollten natürlich treffen mit vielen
menschen in innenräumen vermeiden weil
das virus sohle übertragen wird und wenn
sie sich mit risikogruppen treffen
machen sie vorher bitte
sicherheitshalber einen selbst test auch
wenn sie geimpft oder genesen sind bitte
halten sie immer und überall an die aha
regeln also den abstand einhalten
mund nasenschutz tagen jene regeln
beachten und natürlich das lüften aber
auch wenn sie geimpft sind und auch wenn
sie zusätzlich getestet sind also auch
bei 2g veranstaltungen möglichst
zusätzlich vorsichtsmaßnahmen treffen
und wenn die symptome einer akuten
atemwegsinfektion haben dann bitte
bleiben sie zu hause und kontaktieren
ihren arzt bitte lasst uns alle diese
maßnahmen zusammen mit tragen wir
schaffen es eben nur gemeinsam diesen
tanker um im bild zu bleiben zu bremsen
ich fasse das noch mal kurz zusammen die
täglichen fallzahlen die wir im moment
sehen die dürfen wir einfach nicht mehr
hinnehmen jeden tag infizieren sich
zehntausende menschen in unserem land
davon werden jeweils einige hundert
sterben dieser eimer wasser der ist
ausgeschüttet
dieses wasser kriegen wir da nicht mehr
rein das ist geschehen
warten wir bitte nicht darauf dass
jemand anderes etwas macht lassen sie
uns jeder und jeder mit unseren eigenen
entscheidungen dafür sorgen dass wir
diesen tanker bremsen gemeinsam kriegen
wir das im griff aber es erfordert
wirklich unsere gemeinsame anstrengungen
danken
herzlichen dank professor wille
jetzt kommen wir zu fragen bitte an
unser frage regime denken eine frage
eine zusatzfrage ich habe auch schon
über zehn hier vorliegen und versuchen
wie die alle abzuarbeiten ich beginne
mit online sascha meyer von dpa frage an
herrn spahn und professor wähler bund
und länder haben schwellen für schärfere
corona maßnahmen vereinbart die an die
hospitalisierung rate anknüpfen ist das
wirklich ein geeigneter früh waren die
karte auch wenn die zahlen ja
offensichtlich mehrere tage nach laufen
nicht tagesaktuell sind ich glaube wir
müssen es ist sind schwellenwerte wie
wir es vorher bei den instanzen bei den
infektionen ja auch schwellenwerte
hatten der vor allem auch angeben in
aller regel kommt man ja von unten an
den schwellenwert in welcher dynamik ist
wächst deswegen empfehle ich auch nicht
bis wenn man bei
2,89 ist zu warten bis 3,0 1 ist oder
bei
5,93 als hospitalisierung since it ends
ist so dass man bei 6 und insofern geht
es darum dass man sozusagen eine
größenordnung hat wie auch bei control
kowitz man etwas an zahlen aber dann
doch eben in etwa die gleichen die
größenordnung dass wenn man sozusagen in
diesen bereich hinein kommt dann auch
entsprechende maßnahmen notwendig sind
und im zweifel früher als später also
ich kann jedenfalls nicht empfehlen eben
auch in dem wissen dass es einen
zeitverzug ja gibt aber wir haben
zumindest was die bundesweite raus
vitalisierung des instituts angeht sie
sehen das ja auch die im gestrigen
wochenbericht mittlerweile ja auch fast
und nennen sie das ja wie es bei den
instanzen hatten aus den erfahrungen der
letzten woche immer eine linie die man
auch einfach zeichnen kann weil man
einfach weiß wieviel nachmeldung sondern
größter wahrscheinlichkeit noch kommen
und das können die länder ja auch wenn
man das vorher seht ihr die dynamik
weiter geht also kurzum das sind
wichtige schwellenwerte aber eben nicht
schwellenwerte wo in dem wissen dass es
auch zeitverzug in der meldung gibt wo
man nur erst handeln sollte wenn man
drüber liegt sondern im zweifel sich
vorher schon die dynamik anschaut und im
zweifel auch
dann eben nicht auf den letzten wert
noch wartet
ja ich verstehe das auch so sie können
sich sicher sein dass alle menschen die
sich mit dieser pandemie wirklich
ernsthaft fachlich beschäftigen und
diese werte erhalten bzw errechnen
monitoren dass die natürlich auch die
anderen werte mit dem kopf haben und ich
sehe das natürlich auch so dass man
nicht bis zum letzten moment wartet
sondern dass dies wirklich die
allerletzte handlungsoption ist und so
verstehe ich das und ich weiß dass in
allen bundesländern diejenigen die dort
arbeiten in den gesundheitsämtern als
auch natürlich die solchen referent der
länder diejenigen die dafür zuständig
sind wie diese daten erfasst werden dass
sie natürlich schon bevor die ampel
wirklich knallrot ist warnungen geben
sie glauben doch nicht ernsthaft dass
irgendein solchen reform im land nicht
auf die inzidenz schauen natürlich sind
die inzidenz noch wichtig und die its
belastung ich kann nur mal kurz sagen es
gibt drei
wichtige faktoren dass einen die
inzidenz reflektieren die infektions
dynamik das ist der früheste die zweite
sind die hospitalisierung die infect
reflektieren das krankheitsgeschehen die
schwere des krankheitsgeschehens das
dritte dann ist die rate auf die tsg ist
ein indikator für die belastung des
gesundheitssystems und natürlich haben
die leute das alles im blick ganz sicher
herr professor wieder inwieweit macht es
dann doch tatsächlich sinn das waren
jetzt wie hier in berlin seit einer
woche in restaurants in sportclubs zweig
eingeführt hat nur noch geimpft gewesen
aber andererseits die mitarbeiter der
kellner oder der der security mann
vermutlich eventuell gar nicht geimpft
ist oder irgendein schnell dass
inwieweit macht das den sinn wenn man
nicht konsequent zweig durchsetzt
sondern die besucher müssen zweig sein
und der mitarbeiter kann halt 3g mittel
schnell dass sein macht das sinn also
ich habe ich weiß nicht genau wie in
jedem bundesland das umgesetzt wird ich
weiß nur dass nicht nur ich sondern auch
minister sparen und dass alle menschen
die wollen und die verstanden haben wie
gefährlich dieses virus ist und
vielleicht sie sich über tragen dass die
innenräume wir halten natürlich zweig
für sinnvoll das betrifft natürlich alle
menschen in dem setting ich meine jeder
kann prinzipiell angesteckt sein oder
eben nicht und das heißt mit 2g
regelungen ist natürlich die
wirkungsvoller desto umfangreicher sie
ist das heißt also alle personen
betrifft und natürlich auch je stärker
sie kontrolliert werden da sind wir bei
einem thema was wir auch seit wochen und
monaten
ansprechen das ist auch durch
unterschiedlich da gibt es ja auch paar
anekdoten es gibt keine systematischen
untersuchung aber
nochmal wenn eine zweijährige nicht
konsequent umgesetzt wird dann kann sie
auch nicht richtig wirken das ist doch
klar und
also ich kann nur wir sind uns sicher
dass wenn zweig gemacht wird und es
nicht konsequent umgesetzt wird dass es
dann nicht die wirkung hat dies bei
konsequenter umgesetzt wo immer das ist
ob das nun restaurant ist aber ist jetzt
völlig wurscht also wenn man etwas nicht
umsetzt dann wird es nicht und es muss
schluss sein damit dass man diese
laissez faire haltung hat wir schützen
uns gegenseitig damit und alle
diejenigen die solche örtlichkeiten
betreiben sollen sie ihn prüfen hinaus
das gilt natürlich dann auch für fußball
bundesliga das gilt für alles hätte ist
ist doch klar also eine regel die nicht
eingehalten wird macht keinen sinn und
vor allen dingen es kommt dir dazu noch
und echtes problem es wird er dann
teilweise suggeriert dass die maßnahme
nicht wirkt aber wenn sie gar nicht
implementiert wird dann kann sie
natürlich auch gar nicht war endlich
übrigens noch einmal ergänzend sagen
weil ich jetzt selbst
mehreren settings robson restaurant oder
eine veranstaltung ist selbst darauf
hingewiesen habe in den letzten wochen
dass wir eine app kostenlos zur
verfügung stellen die kann jeder im app
store herunterladen
mit der man die zertifikate auch prüfen
kann also die prüfung sollte eben nicht
nur stattfinden in dem mal irgendwie
drauf guckt so es gibt eine app
kostenlos mit der kann jeder im zweifel
auch bei seinem
weil sie einem freundschaftsbesuch wird
aber jedenfalls dass im zertifikat
überprüfen und übrigens zur überprüfung
gehört auch der personalausweis oder ein
nachweis der identität auch der teil ist
natürlich wichtig wir haben ja schon
gesagt 3g war zu oft 0 g und 2g sollte
jetzt eigentlich nur gewähren sondern
muss jetzt auch konsequent zweig oder im
zweig plus sein
angela mißlbeck vom rc nachrichtendienst
fragt in österreich steht nun ein
lockdown nicht nur für ungeimpfte bevor
schließen sie das für deutschland aus
herr spahn und frau probleme von ansa
fragten die selbe richtung wenn die lage
so dramatisch ist die schwerste wie sie
gerade gesagt haben wir sparen warum
geht man eigentlich nicht sofort in den
lock down und die welt sprechen
also wir sind in einer lage wo man auch
wenn das jetzt wieder dann die ticker
meldung dazu produziert aber wo man auch
nichts ausschließen sollte
die frage ist nur ob wenn ich viel
besser vermeiden sollten dass wir in
solchen lagen und in solche
entscheidungsnotwendigkeiten kommen und
eins ist ja einmal mehr die lehre umso
früher konsequent gehandelt wird desto
früher riecht man eben die dynamik also
in dem moment wo sie sich sozusagen
abzeichnet wir hatten ja lange eine
lineare entwicklung in dieser vierten
welle und dann in der zweiten
oktoberhälfte ging es hoch ist ab keiner
wusste genau wann aber es war eben mit
den modellierungen zu erwarten dass es
mal dazu kommen kann mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit und in dem moment wo
das sozusagen abhebt und exponentiell
wird um so frühzeitig eher man eingreift
desto weniger
hart muss dann am ende auch das
gesamtpaket sein deswegen kann ich nicht
empfehlen was auszuschließen und
deswegen haben wir ja auch dafür
geworben den instrumentenkasten der
länder nicht
unnötig zu beschränken also es ist
wichtig dass es eine rechtsgrundlage
gibt aber genauso wichtig ist eben dass
die länder möglichst viele instrumente
zur verfügung haben und dazu gehören zum
beispiel eben auch die frage von hotels
von beförderungen von mobilität in und
durch deutschland in dieser situation
und ich finde es gut dass jetzt etwa zum
beispiel auch die sächsische
staatsregierung genau solche maßnahmen
angekündigt und hat nicht nur und jetzt
ja auch umsetzt nächste frage herr
kollege
habe den körper vom zdf ersparen sie
haben ja im sommer schon gewarnt vor der
vierten belem auch von den sidenten bis
zu 800 gesprochen warum ist es ihnen
trotzdem nicht gelungen das land vor der
vierten welle zumindest in der harte zu
schützen und dann herrn villa hätte ich
noch eine frage sie haben ja auch im
sommer gewusst was auf uns zukommt haben
den letzten tagen sehr drastisch gewarnt
aus heutiger sicht hätte das früher
passieren müssen
also zuerst einmal ja sag ich jedenfalls
für mich auch selbstkritisch hätte
früher deutlicher noch deutlicher auf
das hinweisen sollen und müssen was sich
entwickeln kann und jedenfalls bei den
quoten die wir haben dann ja auch eben
entwickeln wird das ist ja das was wir
gemeinsam immer wieder auch vorgestellt
haben die modellierung des robert koch
instituts gibt es seit juli august sind
zudem zu dem was bei welcher impfquote
passieren kann
die beschlüsse im übrigen auch
beschlüsse zum booster an zu
auffrischimpfung ich die haben wir
anfang august gefasst sehr nicht so dass
die wichtigkeit von auffrischimpfungen
bei variablen gruppen er ist irgendwie
den letzten drei wochen erkannt wäre und
dann ist es auch unterschiedlich stark
umgesetzt worden und im nachhinein
hätten zweifel ja noch genauer in der
umsetzung dann in den bund länder
vereinbarung bei jedem einzelnen schauen
müssen die einen haben ihre pflegeheime
geimpft gehabt
ist herbstanfang andere haben da ja erst
angefangen
was dann da passiert oder eben drei geht
es zu auf 0 g war am ende
ist es jetzt aber so wie es ist das ist
ja die situation vor der wir stehen aber
ich schon auch wert darauf und jetzt
ohne das jetzt irgendwie sozusagen ich
auch für mich gelten zu lassen
im rückblick dass die dinge gesprochen
bekannt und im übrigen an vielen stellen
auch beschlossen waren die man an geht
um sicher und besser durch herbst und
winter zu kommen das gleiche gilt ja
auch für die für die kommunikativen
fragen als wir über die epidemische lage
diskutiert haben erstmalig pro 4 wochen
weil die inzidenz bei 70
dann muss man ja für sich selbst
erkennen dass sozusagen die
kommunikative wirkung die eigentlich mit
der rechtlichen debatte verbunden war
eine kleine grüne keine gute war es kann
wenn ich das selbst kritisch kann kannst
vielleicht auch die ampel selbstkritisch
also zur kommunikation ich möchte noch
mal folgendes sagen wenn sie mich direkt
ansprechen das robert-koch-institut hat
jede dieser vier wellen rechtzeitig
voraus jede dieser vier wellen natürlich
weiß man nicht wie hoch die welle geht
aber jede dieser vier wellen das heißt
also dass
wurde angemahnt werden im juli diese
publikation
erstellt die beruhte auf einer
modellierung am 8 juli publiziert auch
vorgestellt in den rahmen in sozialen
medien in der bpk hier und wir haben
dann aufbauen auf dieser modellierung
kontroll co wird überarbeitet das ist ja
auch schon seit letztem jahr unser
strategiepapier und haben wir rein
geschrieben an mich als im juli
wo ist der impfungen sollten jetzt
geplant und vorbereitet werden die
bevölkerung soll zu möglichen szenarien
für den herbst informieren mögliche
belastung der its monitoring impfquote
in freundschaft ausbruchsgeschehen
basismaßnahmen einzuhalten auch für
geimpfte und genießen steht da drin im
juli möchte die auch mal klar stellen ja
steht im juli da drin
bevölkerungs basierte kontakt
reduzierende maßnahmen sollte man im
kopf haben
altenpflegeheime sollten sich mit einer
systematischen test strategie auf den
herbst vorbereiten und warum haben wir
das gesagt weil wir gesagt haben in dem
papier wenn die impfquoten nicht höher
sind wenn sie so und so hoch sind dann
kann dies oder jenes geschehen und das
heißt also
diese dinge sind klar angesprochen
worden
wie das kommuniziert wird wieder das
antizipiert wird zu welcher zeit wann
sie sind die medienvertreter sie wissen
dass viel besser als wir und wie oft
habe ich hier gesessen mein professor
thorsten sagt er wird kein papagei ich
bin schon lange der papagei wie oft habe
ich hier gesessen und habe das immer
wieder gesagt
also
so ist es einfach ja das sind die fakten
und die sollten wir alle nicht vergessen
und ich sage noch einmal zu dem gab es
auch beschlüsse
bund länder vereinbarung zu nahezu all
diesen themen man gibt sich die gelten
ja noch an der stelle was neu ist und
das aber auch zu sagen weil wir
natürlich in der entwicklung immer noch
erkenntnisse haben sind zwei dinge das
eine ist die erkenntnis dass über die
besonders verwundbaren und über die die
älteren wir haben dann für über
60-jährige etwa das auffrischimpfung
anfang august beschlossen mit der
erkenntnis aus israel vor allem wir
gesehen haben es macht eben viel sind
auch für die anderen altersgruppen weil
wir eine zweite erkenntnis hatten die
jedenfalls in dieser deutlichkeit vorher
noch nicht da war das nämlich eben eben
zeitablauf vor allem das angesteckt
werden von geimpften wieder zunimmt dass
also das erste wo die im wirkung
nachlässt die frage ist wie gut hilft
der impfschutz gegen das man sich selbst
an steckt man wird zwar nicht krank gott
sei dank immer noch zu sehr hohen
prozentzahlen 90 prozent und mehr aber
das risiko sich anzustecken das
weiterzugeben und auch diese erkenntnis
war eine die dann eben in den letzten
wochen erst umfassend da war und dann
aber ja auch zu entsprechenden maßnahmen
und empfehlungen geführt hat wie eben
das umfassende auffrischimpfung und
jetzt haben wir auch den gleichklang mit
der stiko empfehlung für die über 18
jahre
eine frage von holger möhle von general
anzeiger und zwar ein professor wieder
warum weiß dass rk ii in seinen wochen
berichten nicht deutlicher die zahl der
ungehinderten in den jeweiligen
altersgruppen aus und deutlich zu machen
dass derzeit vor allem ungeimpfte diese
vierte würde anschieben und so den druck
auf die ungeimpften zu erhöhen
ja ich bin ein großer freund des
general-anzeigers ich komme aus der
gegend aber dann möchte ich
widersprechen wochenbericht kommt ja
immer donnerstags und der war gestern
und da ist diese grafik grün das ist
genau diese grafik die der kohle oder
der herr von der general-anzeiger
fordert also die ist dort drin wir
hatten die vorher nur alle vier wochen
drin aber sie ist jetzt wöchentlich drin
also diese grafiken sind gar die 1 hatte
ich ihn eben gezeigt die zeigt sehr
deutlich dass ungeimpfte eben deutlich
in hörerzahl vielfaches mehr krank
werden schwer erkrankt und realisiert
werden also die frage erst mal direkt
beantwortet mit einem faktischen blatt
dann habe ich noch eine weitere
fachfrage von andré schmidt von der
deutschen welle werden bereits daten zur
booster effektivität für deutschland
nach oben beziehungsweise veröffentlicht
nein das können wir auch gar nicht wir
haben gerade erst relativ wenig menschen
gepustet vor sehr kurzer zeit natürlich
werden wir auch die effektivität messen
aber das wird noch einige monate dauern
dafür sind die daten einfach zu wenige
in zu kurzer zeit das können wir noch
nicht ermitteln was wir haben aber nur
ergänzend ist es auch zum teil durch
ministerium finanziert sind einfach
studien zur stärkung des immunsystems
mal bei den besonders verwundbaren den
älteren und vorher kranken hier in der
charité professor sander zum beispiel
der auch schon öfter hier mit uns war
und andere haben solche studien gemacht
und man sieht gerade wenn jetzt im
krankheits schutz geht teilweise
verzwanzigfachen zum beispiel der
antikörper nach einer auffrischimpfung
bei diesen besonders verwundbaren aber
sozusagen im feld kann man das natürlich
jetzt erst im zeitablauf dann auch sie
dann noch eine frage zur technik
christian geinitz von der faz fragt zur
hospitalisierung rate treibt es die
hospitalisierung rate in einem
bundesland einer region nach oben wenn
corona patienten aus anderen regionen
dorthin verlegt werden also nach dem
kleeblatt prinzip inwieweit werden wir
falsche anreize gesetzt
es gilt das wohnortprinzip bei der
meldung der hospitalisierung since it
ends und insofern ein gleichzeitig ist
aber natürlich wichtig wenn sie von
einer region in die andere verlegen ist
dann in der region in diese hinein
verlegt haben das bett belegt
also es ist sozusagen zufließt wenn ich
in die osb tabuisierung intelligent sein
aber gleichzeitig muss natürlich auch
die region für sich ja abschätzen das
wird auch passieren was tatsächlich dann
auch an kapazität da ist
frage herr spahn
hat der kanzleramtsminister und arzt hat
die korona pandemie als große
naturkatastrophe bezeichnet ist dieser
begriff eigentlich korrekt oder
verschiebt er nicht verantwortungen
naturkatastrophen sind unvorhersehbar
und planbar das war doch aber bei der
pandemie nicht der fall hat herr braun
sozusagen da nicht den falschen begriff
verwendet
also dass dieses virus so über die
menschheit und über die welt kommt ich
weiß nicht was sie wussten vorher aber
das haben wir jedenfalls jetzt für diese
konkrete situation für den konkreten
zeitpunkt jahreswechsel 219 220 er nicht
irgendwie schon ein jahr vorher gewusst
oder ein halbes sondern und sind sofern
ein naturereignis weil mutmaßlich
jedenfalls mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
ist der über sprung vom tier auf den
menschen gewesen ist eines solchen virus
und ich denke das ist vor allem ja auch
ein bild das im übrigen auch ich schon
gelingt nicht benutzt dabei das in
deutlich macht dass das etwas ist was
über uns gekommen ist der unterschied zu
einer naturkatastrophe wie wir sie
ansonsten vor augen haben oder anderen
katastrophen ist die meisten gehen nicht
18 monate die sind mit den folgen
natürlich wie etwa in den flutgebieten
ja auch lange sehr lange beschäftigt
aber wir sind noch gar nicht in der
folge abarbeitung wir sind noch in der
situation und das ist natürlich ein
unterschied zu den meisten anderen
katastrophen eine frage an wieder
diejenigen die sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen auch im hinblick auf booster
sagen damit würde man ja ein abonnement
auf sechs monate
auffrischung buchen
also sozusagen alle halbe jahre muss
dann neu gemixt werden gibt es
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse dass die
dritte impfung jetzt dann einen doch
längeren schutz als über erneute sechs
monate hinaus bietet also die erste
aussage ist korrekt also diejenigen dass
das wissen wir jetzt seit einigen wochen
dass der immunschutz nach diesen ersten
beiden impfungen zu etwa sechs monate
hält das variiert natürlich auch von
altersgruppe zu altersgruppe aber das
ist schon ein guter parameter gerade
wenn es um krankheit und tod geht es ist
tatsächlich so wenn man also diese
impfung abgehalten hat dann ist der die
dritte impfung damit sozusagen abonniert
wenn man damit einfach den mut schulz
noch einmal deutlich erhöht die frage
die zweite ist natürlich nicht zu
beantworten also wir haben das oft
gesagt im vorfeld gehen davon aus dass
man sich nochmal weiter ostern werden
wird in zukunft wir wissen aber nicht
welche zeiträume das sind auch da kann
ich wieder nur sagen das sind der
beobachtungsstudien wenn die ersten
menschen im letzten jahr so im november
geimpft wurden dann können wir natürlich
gar nicht sagen wann deren immunität
soweit abfällt dass sie wieder bewusst
werden sollten aber ich sage in die
überlegung die wir persönlich haben und
das heißt also wir im rk ii und viele
wissenschaftler wir gehen ja irgendwann
in diesen zustand über dass das virus
endemisch ist also das dürfte ja nicht
aus unserer gesellschaft verschwinden
sondern was da sein wird sich mehr an
uns anpassen und wir werden eine
steigende grund immunität haben und dann
ist ein mögliches szenario also das weiß
ich nicht ob das ein sei dabei möglich
wäre dass man so wie man jetzt gegen die
grippe impft dann jedes jahr vor der
saison weil es hat eine saisonalität
also vor dem winter könnte sein in dem
fall was bei grippe zur zeit zu haben
dass irgendwann wieder dahin kommen dass
wir sagen so bestimmte gruppen also die
alten hochhaltigen immunsupprimierten
schwangere dass die jährlich geimpft
wenn es könnte sein das wäre für uns
persönlich die ist eine plausible
annahme ob das so sein wird weiß ich
nicht aber das ist eine plausible
annahme weil das virus ja nicht
verschwinden wird und wir sollten eben
dann immer noch diejenigen die nach wie
vor von dem virus auch wenn sie
infiziert werden schwere krankheiten
haben dass die sich mit schützen und
dieses aber normal ist auch ein schönes
auto es ist nämlich kostenfrei und es
bewahrt ihre gesundheit ich habe noch
kein besseres abonnement kennengelernt
bislang
dann habe ich die nächste frage von
gisela breuer vom gesundheitspolitischen
information steen an herr spahn es ist
doch mittlerweile klar dass auch
geimpfte pandemie treiber sind dass sie
sich im rahmen von 2g anstecken und das
virus weiter verbreitet wäre es nicht
das gebot der stunde 1 g also alle
getesteten zweig plus über einzuführen
warum sollte es überhaupt noch zweig
ohne plus geben
für ein frühzeitiges und umfassendes
zweig plus habe ich ja bereits in der
letzten woche hier geworden wir sehen
übrigens in einigen auch modellierung
wieder natürlich aber es gibt einige
modellierung wie auch aufzeigen welchen
unterschied welche maßnahme macht die
haben wir ja gott sei dank in den
letzten monaten auch immer häufiger
gehabt man sieht dass zweig plus
konsequent angewendet das potenzial hat
den er wert um 0,5 punkte zu senken wenn
man weiß dass wir jetzt so bei
1,1 plus - immer sind wird die maßnahme
schon einen ziemlich entscheidenden
unterschied macht deswegen ist es ja gut
dass ich zumindest erstmalig auch als
konsequent anzuwenden maßnahme ab einem
bestimmten schritt in einem bund länder
beschluss ist wir sind im zweifel dafür
im zweifel früher als später in zweifel
die umfassendere maßnahmen zu machen
und durch die hohe incidents die wir
haben und die veränderung im zeitablauf
das eben auch kämpfte sich wieder
stärker anstecken können ja sind auch
geimpfte teil des infektionsgeschehen es
aber ich finde trotzdem sehr wichtig für
die frage der belastung des systems für
die frage auch wie groß der unterschied
ist das ist ja die grafik wie sie gerade
hoch gehalten haben etwa in der instanz
auch infektionsgeschehen machen die doch
relativ viel kleinere gruppe der
erwachsenen etwa 15 millionen der
ungeimpften erwachsene etwa 15 jungen
und erwachsenen
den größten teil unseres problems aus
ist ist einfach die wahrheit da gibt es
jetzt auch wenig dran zu drehen und zu
wenden und um es mit dem
bundespräsidenten zu sagen ich verstehe
einfach nicht was noch passieren muss
bis man erkennt dass die impfungen man
möchte ja jeden irgendwie mal einmal auf
diese intensivstation zerren um zu
zeigen welchen unterschied eben die
impfung dann auch machen kann deswegen
jahr zweig plus früh und konsequent ist
der richtige ansatz wenn
ich eine frage von jürgen klöckner vom
handelsblatt wie und wann erfolgt die
umsetzung der impfpflicht in
medizinischen berufen durch den bund
anhand sparen nicht zuerst einmal dass
sich skeptisch bin was eine solche
verpflichtende impfung angeht ist
bekannt das ist aber jetzt nicht
entscheidend in dem moment wo die
mehrheit im bundestag die werden der
mehrheit im bundestag die ampel das
bundesministerium für gesundheit bietet
einen entsprechenden gesetzentwurf zu
erarbeiten
es ist mein amtsverständnis
eben als geschäftsführender minister das
wird an diesem gesetzentwurf natürlich
auch erarbeiten so wie wir auch das
gestern vom bundestag beschlossene
gesetz der ampel für die ampel
erarbeitet haben obwohl ich persönlich
einen anderen weg gegangen wäre welche
wege gegangen werden habe ich ja in
einem brief mitte oktober vor
geschlossenes kurzum unabhängig davon
dass ich persönlich das skeptisch wie
bekannt ist werden wir in dem moment wo
wir ein eine bitte aus der mehrheit des
bundestages haben einen gesetzentwurf zu
erarbeiten den auch erarbeiten
dazu passt die frage von alessandro
editor von funke
auch an sie herr spahn österreich führt
jetzt eine allgemeine impfpflicht 1 ist
dies für deutschland weiterhin
auszuschließen auszuschließen oder ist
es nun auch bei uns im rahmen des
denkbaren falls die pandemie zahlen
weiter steigen
auch da sie also wir haben bis jetzt
eine solche allgemeine impfpflicht ich
kenne jetzt auch das österreichische
modell dazu nicht wie das tatsächlich um
und durchgesetzt werden soll wir haben
etwa bei der verpflichtenden
masernimpfung die im übrigen auf meinen
initiative hin eingeführt worden ist
eine regelung dass eben für das betreten
das arbeiten im bestimmten einrichtung
schule kita gemeinschaftseinrichtungen
übrigens auch andere
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen asylbewerber
unterkünfte anderem mehr dafür der
nachweis erbracht werden muss dass man
gegen masern mumps durch impfung oder
dadurch dass man es durch gemacht hat
das ist ja das regel konstrukt das wir
haben bei der masernimpfung dieses lässt
sich natürlich zumindest rechtlich
frage ob man es politisch in der
abwägung für richtig die andere frage
ist ja ob es rechtlich wie man es recht
nicht umsetzt so würde ich jedenfalls
sagen setzt man dann auch das hier oben
einrichtungs bezogen eben in diesen
einrichtungen wo es entsprechende
notwendigkeiten aus sicht einer
möglichen parlamentsmehrheit gibt wenn
allgemeine impfpflicht
einzuführen durchzusetzen und dabei noch
das land zusammenzuhalten
diskutieren kann man alle ist das ist
das schöne an unserer offenen pluralen
gesellschaft
und die diskussion findet übrigens hat
schon stattgefunden bevor es im stoff
gab zur frage ob es verpflichten die
debatte ist da soll auch geführt werden
da bin ich einfach noch skeptischer
gleichen gefühl dafür hat was das mit
dem land machen würde
dann hab ich jetzt nächstes herrn
heimbach
es klang jetzt schon mehrfach an
trotzdem würde ich gerne noch mal
nachhaken eine frage an sie beide also
vor dem hintergrund der gestern
beschlossenen maßnahmen sind sie der
meinung dass diese ausreichen und welche
wären unmöglich auch wünschenswert
darüber hinaus und meine zweite frage
dreht sich um die hospitalisierung rate
also wein 28 20 lag die ungefähr bei 16
derzeit liegt sie bei 5,3 im vergleich
wirkt das als wäre das gar nicht so
schlimm
dennoch schlagen natürlich die
intensivmedizin dank war der alarm
womöglich gibt es auch weniger intensiv
kapazitäten gerade vielleicht können sie
vielleicht sein dass er wieder zahl
nochmal einordnen wie sich das heute mit
928 20 vergleichen wenn ich kurz mit
letzterem anfangen da sie müssen halt
auch regional schauen wir haben regionen
und bundesländer in deutschland wo die
hospitalisierung incidents deutlich über
16 oder 15 liegt
also insofern gibt es regionale
unterschiede aber die entwicklung ist in
allen regionen leiter
die gleiche und weil sie im regional zum
teil deutlich über der bisherigen
höchstwert um liegt ist ja eben auch das
verlegen von patientinnen und patienten
notwendig und das problem ist ja sie
sind ja nicht am pik wir sind ja
offenkundig nicht am pik bei den
infektionszahlen einfach der letzten
drei vier fünf tage werden wir die
intensiv flüchtigkeit die sich daraus
ergibt ja erst in 10 14 tagen ermessen
können wie können sie vorhersagen in
etwa das eben bei 50.000 neu infizierten
350 400
wahrscheinlich in zehn bis 14 tagen
intensiv wichtig sein werden das heißt
aber der sozusagen die höchstzahl an
intensiv pflichtigen kurbel 19 patienten
in deutschland ist selbst wenn es heute
aufhören würde und sich einander
infiziert noch nicht erreicht das wird
selbst wenn es gelänge ist absolut zu
brechen in den nächsten tagen noch
weiter hoch gehen und das ist absolut
gebrochen wird von heute auf morgen ist
auch nicht abzusehen insofern geht die
belastung weiter hoch gehen und was man
ja mal sehen muss wie diesmal wir haben
auch noch andere patienten als coupé 19
patienten in diesem land und winters ist
immer die zeit wo die intensivstationen
stärker belastet sind als im sommer weil
respiratorische atemwegserkrankung also
historische erkrankungen generell
häufiger vorkommen wir sehen das gerade
auch bei den kindern das rsv
angeht zum beispiel weil es natürlich
auch die schlaganfall und
notfallpatienten weiterhin gibt die
behandelt werden müssen und behandelt
werden sollen und die natürlich dann
auch
die entsprechenden betten brauchen und
deswegen ist das eine die situation
profit 19 weiter im aufwachsen und
gleichzeitig die belastung die wir haben
und übrigens die belastung für die
intensivpflege kräfte ist bei einem coup
19 patienten auch einfach noch höher als
bei anderen patienten weil man in voller
montur ist 45 stunden am stück im
zweifel gar nicht dazu kommt was zu
trinken nicht wasser lassen kann es ist
eine enorme körperliche belastung für
die intensivpflege kräfte von der sich
glaube ich viele gar kein bild machen
was das bedeutet dass sie mir sehr froh
dass das gestern nochmal adressiert
worden ist das ein bonus geben soll
nochmal für die pflege aber vor allem
für die intensivpflege und der muss
jetzt auch mal spürbar sein also ich
würde sagen 5000 euro plus iks für
intensivpflege kräfte wird das was
irgendwie angemessen wäre um mal zu
sagen und zwar nicht nur für die
pflegekräfte auf intensiv auf das
reinigungspersonal auf denen alle die da
auf den intensivstationen arbeiten mit
kurbel 19 patienten haben im umgang mit
coop 19 patienten eine echt schwere
belastung im vergleich auch zu anderen
intensivpatienten und das haben sie
jetzt zum vierten mal und das haben sie
in den berechtigten gefühl dass wenn
sich doch mehr hätten impfen lassen so
jedenfalls nicht nötig gewesen wäre und
insofern finde ich das wichtig dass das
gestern eine einigung war als zweiter
wenn ich das nur kurz nord oder wollen
sie zu der frage legen
könnte auch
ich ergänze das dann kurz machen sie
doch jetzt die ergänzung einfach so dass
wenn noch mal wenn sie die zahlen fragen
5 bis 15 zum beispiel also nochmal diese
hospitalisierung residenz ist eher ein
ausdruck für die krankheit schwere und
sie sehen eben dass wir durch die
impfungen ja insgesamt eben weniger
schwere fälle haben ja das heißt also
darum ist dieser faktor geringer der
andere aspekt den ich aber auch noch
sagen möchte bei diesen überlegungen die
man macht für so ein kontrollgerät
papier wir haben ja leider jetzt nicht
mehr so viel oder bis jetzt zumindest
hatten wir nicht so viel kontakt
reduzierende maßnahmen wie im letzten
jahr sie sehen das sehr schön an den
atemwegsinfektionen wir hatten letztes
jahr ein historisch niedriges niveau an
atemwegsinfektionen
jetzt haben wir das wieder und ich will
auch genau wie minister spannung auf die
kinder verweisen wir haben wirklich
situationen wo inzwischen kinder auf
intensivstationen sind und die werden
teilweise über 12 stunden verlegt weil
die intensivbetten der kinder auch nicht
mehr alle verfügbar sind das heißt also
die zahl ist deshalb runtergesetzt der
schwellenwert weil wir wissen dass
kowitz selber weniger große belastung
macht also durch die impfung ist die
krankheit schwere reduziert da noch mal
der punkt großbritannien sind sie denn
es ist ein maß für die schwere und
deshalb dürfen nicht vergessen dass eben
noch die krankenhausbetten und die
intensivbetten auch noch für die anderen
gebraucht wenn wir haben eine
zusatzbelastung dadurch dass wir jetzt
die atemwegsinfektion nicht so stark
unterdrücken wie letztes jahr das kommt
dazu dass muss man berechnet wenn man so
strategien aufbaut was kommt alles auf
unser gesundheitssystem tun sondern war
die andere frage er noch das reicht
als einzig sei normal ist klar dass sich
konzentrieren aus impfen reicht
jedenfalls nicht ich sehe wie gerade an
vielen stellen immer wieder aufs neue
die beschlüsse und vereinbarungen zum
impfen herausgehoben werden sie sind
auch wichtig sie sind nicht das was in
der lage in der wir mittlerweile sind
die dynamik bricht sondern das sind eben
kontakt reduzierende maßnahmen jedes
einzelnen im alltag
und im staatliche entsprechende
maßnahmen und ob die abstufung von 22 g
plus und weitere maßnahmen sowie sie
vereinbart sind reichen oder nicht das
werden wir in den nächsten tagen sehen
ich kann so werben für ein schnelles
entschlossenes umsetzen und
kontrollieren
und gleichzeitig ist es ja gut dass
vereinbart ist dass am 9 dezember
spätestens am 9 dezember
bund und länder noch mal auf die lage
schauen und übrigens auch auf die lage
auf die frage schauen ob es eben
zusätzliche maßnahme möglichkeiten für
die länder braucht also über das gerade
eben im bundesrat beschlossene hinaus
dazu passt die frage von sebastian
heinrich vom nachrichtenportal watson
ersparen
sind sie müssten aus ihrer sicht nicht
eigentlich auch clubs bars und konzerte
grundsätzlich schließen
da jedenfalls indem situation oder in
den regionen herr professor wieland auf
control witting gewesen wo stufe 2 was
übrigens die höchste stufe ist in dem
konzept des 0 1 2 in den regionen die
diese parameter erreichen
infektionszahlen hospitalisierung since
it ends und anteil an intensivbetten
belegt sollten ja auch clubs und bars im
zweifel lieber schließen als zweig plus
machen und eine großveranstaltung kann
man auch klein machen indem man einfach
die teilnehmerzahl enormen begrenzt also
man muss ja wenn man sie nicht absagen
will was im zweifel auch die bessere
variante ist kann man immer noch enorm
die teilnehmerzahlen begrenzen und den
zutritt über 2g plus und auch das
empfiehlt sich spätestens mal in den
regionen die eben entsprechende werte
haben ich will nochmals ich verstehe ja
dass einige darin wir haben landkreise
die haben sogar noch ich glaube unter
103 und sie denn sogar noch als nur noch
wenige aber das geht natürlich sagen
kann sein dass bei uns das gleiche geld
vollständig wie bei dem mit 1500
verstehe ich ja aber die entwicklung ist
halt überall die gleiche und das ist ja
eben auch der hinweis auf die nationale
lage die wir die wir gerade haben dann
noch eine
klärung von florian dann von stuttgarter
zeitung stuttgarter nachrichten
und zwar an sie professor wähler die in
thüringen liegt die hospitalisierung
since i dance mehr als viermal so hoch
wie in sachsen obwohl die zahl der
neuinfektionen thüringen geringer ist
und die frage lautet woran liegt das
gute frage kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
richtig sagt diel ich beantworten wenn
ich das richtig im kopf sind die
fraktionierung 's raten nicht besonders
unterschiedlich
ich kann es ihnen nicht beantworten
tut mir leid habe ich keine erklärung
für dann als nächste fragestellerin
forschung
es ist schon einmal das thema pflege
bonus da würde ich gern mal nachfragen
den beschlüssen gestern ersparen heißt
dass der bund prüfen ob er die
finanzmittel zur verfügung hatte ich war
bis jetzt davon ausgegangen dass ihr
haus betrifft was die finanzmittel
betrifft ist das so wird das eine prämie
seien für die ihr haus zuständig ist
dann wird die geben und in welcher höhe
eben diese 5000 euro für sex oder doch
niedriger wissen sie die besondere haus
herausforderungen dieser zeit ist ja
dieser übergangszeit die er offenkundig
auch die entscheidung und die
entscheidungs geschwindigkeit nicht
immer einfacher macht auch im bund
länder zusammenspiel aber jedenfalls das
herausfordernde ist ja dass wenn da
steht der bund
das eben im
großen und ganzen entscheidungen der
werdenden ampel sind also ich entscheide
alles was der minister entscheiden kann
auch natürlich in der verantwortung die
ich als minister habe das sind die
verordnung das ist die frage dass wir
gerade beschaffen das war letzte woche
ja auch thema natürlich die medikamente
und in gesprächen sind mit pfizer msd
die verhandlung wo ich mich auch selber
engagiere und und einschalten aber
ansonsten
im zweifel ist immer schwieriger ist die
frage wie wir interagieren mit den
ländern wo wir kostenlos was also ist es
die dinge kay ministerium machen aber in
dem moment wo es um gesetzgebung geht
ist das natürlich eine enge rückkopplung
mit der werdenden mehrheit was ich bilde
mehrheit im deutschen bundestag wichtig
und am ende dann eben auch sozusagen die
arbeit
wünsche und aufträge so verstehe ich
mich als geschäftsführende minister und
wir uns auch im ministerium
und deswegen muss jetzt eben vor allem
diese werden der ampel uns einen hinweis
geben wie sie sich die konkrete
ausgestaltung vorstellt wenn gewünscht
mache ich auch da gerne vorschläge die
mache ich dann aber zuerst intern weiter
auch in der konkreten ausgestaltung und
dann muss natürlich vor allem auch der
finanzminister sagen welches finanzielle
volumen das ganze haben soll also wir
können alles in der größenordnung nach
oben ist die skala sozusagen denkbar in
der dem was denkbar ist offen es muss ja
am ende eben auch mit dem
finanzministerium geklärt sein das
heisst das bully gestern tatsächlich gar
nicht über eine höhere geredet da steht
viel gebäudes drin und über die höhe
wurde in den ganzen beratungen nicht
gesprochen
das ist so außer dass ich gestern den
gleichen hinweis gegeben hat wie gerade
eben das aus meiner sicht bei den
intensiv pflegekräften und dem intensiv
personalien falls eine ziemlich dort aus
meiner sicht als ziemlich deutliche
bonus wichtig wäre also ein paar hundert
euro brauchen wir denen nicht kommen da
werden die zu recht
frustriert
dann habe ich die frage von markus
overmann vom bayerischen rundfunk die
infektionszahlen
sie gerade mein bild schon verrutscht
die infektionszahlen an den schulen
neben zu wieso wird dort kein wechsel
unterricht eingeführt beziehungsweise
wieso werden schulen offen gehalten er
hat dass er niemand gericht
nicht berufen fühlt es ist ja als es am
ende sind es natürlich entscheidungen
der länder wo ich ja schon froh bin dass
die entscheidung dass da irgendwie in
eine woche nach der anderen überall auch
masken vorgaben ja gefallen sind gern
mal so schnell gucken derzeit lange wie
auf einmal alle masken pflichten
gefallen sind dass das jetzt wieder eben
in seiner notwendigkeit auch erkannt ist
sind das ja die schwersten entscheidung
und ich finde es grundsätzlich richtig
dass das schließen von schulen und kitas
jetzt hier nicht irgendwie die erste
maßnahme ist über die wir nachdenken und
über die wir reden also solange es noch
bilder von feiernden menschen auf
straßen gibt finde ich nicht dass schul
und kita schließungen
die maßnahmen seien sollten über die wir
auch nur nachdenken sondern da sind
andere zuerst dran
dann hab ich im saal
polieren
das
ja fabian busch von de und gmx eine
frage zu weihnachten was glauben sie wie
wird weihnachten in diesem jahr ausgehen
es sind jetzt nur noch fünf wochen
glauben sie dass ist erreichen wir zu
appellieren die kontakte zu beschränken
am ende des tages sprechen sie sich das
abschließend zutrauen das vorherzusagen
jetzt fünf wochen vorher am ende des
tages und beginnen jedes tages liegt an
uns
wir haben schon gesehen dass wenn wir
schaffen kontakte und damit dass die
infektions wahrscheinlichkeit
übertragungs wahrscheinlichkeit deutlich
zu reduzieren alle miteinander im alltag
und durch entsprechende maßnahmen das in
dem moment wo der wert fällt nicht auf
0,99 sondern auf 0,8 oder 0,7 das
genauso schnell wieder runter gehen kann
wie es hoch gegangen ist dafür muss aber
ist auch eine deutliche einschränkung
geben denkt ja immer von 1,0 auf 0,8 das
klingt ja gar nicht so viel aber es ist
natürlich wenn sie über exponentielles
wachstum oder
eben die die gegenrichtung reden ist das
viel die frage wie weihnachten wird da
traue ich mir noch keine aussage zu zu
ich kann nur sagen sie liegt an uns an
jedem von uns also ich möchte das auch
noch mal ergänzen wenn wir heute
massnahmen treffen dann sehen wir deren
effekt vielleicht in zwei wochen etwa
also wenn heute etwas getan wird dann
sieht man ob das eine wirkung hatte in
zwei wochen ja das sind hängt also daran
was getan wird das ist ganz klar aber
wenn wir in bereichen sind wie in bayern
in sachsen oder auch in thüringen wo wir
wirklich hohe sehr sehr hohe instanzen
haben bis man da wieder die situation
deeskaliert dauert natürlich länger als
in situationen wo man schon früher diese
maßnahmen ein das heißt also es hängt
das hängt zu 100 prozent davon ab welche
maßnahmen beschlossen werden und wie sie
umgesetzt werden und fünf wochen ist
keine lange zeit um hier mal ganz klar
zu bleiben also die maßnahmen müssen
stringent implementiert wenn zur schule
noch mal ganz kurz
wir haben uns sehr häufig sehr klar dazu
geäußert dass wir möchten dass schüler
und schülerinnen bestmöglich geschützt
sind wir haben hier in der bpk mehrfach
gesagt wir sind die die die wegnahme der
masten pflicht halten wir für nicht
zielführend
es ist klar dass es übertragung in
schulen gibt wir möchten unsere kinder
schützen wir wollen dass wir alle wollen
dass die kinder geschützt sind wir
wollen auch das indy schule gehen also
können man die schulen nur aufhalten
wenn man die kinder schützt durch
konzepte es gibt es drei leitlinien das
ist der höchste grad von leitlinien was
besseres gibt es nicht die deutschen
seit letztem jahr dann müssen die ihm
umgesetzt werden das ist da sind vorbei
am selben thema die möglichkeiten sind
da die tests sind da die masken sind da
die konzepte sind da und dort wo sie
nicht konsequent umgesetzt werden der
wird natürlich dann eine schulklasse
früher in quarantäne gehen und mehr
schülerinnen und schüler infiziert
werden und unabhängig davon auch wenn
ganz wenig kinder ernsthaft krank werden
ich habe nach wie vor den anspruch ich
möchte nicht dass in unserem land kinder
zwingend schwer erkranken auch wenn
bislang sehr wenig kinder verstorben
sind ich möchte nicht dass irgendein
einziges kind verstirbt an einer
infektion die wir präventiv hätten
verhindern können also das ganz klar
gesagt wenn ich noch mal habe ich letzte
woche schon aber ich finde das einfach
eindrucksvoll auf die unterschiedlichen
impfquoten auch bei den 12 bis 17
jährigen hinweisen es gibt bundesländer
da sind über 60 prozent der 12 bis 17
jährigen mindestens einmal geimpft
werden bundesländer da ist es nicht mal
die hälfte also es geht dabei sind ja
auch eltern beteiligt und irgendwann
wird vielleicht auch nicht nur um die
entscheidung für einen selbst sondern
dann auch für die entscheidung für die
anderen in der familie und zum thema
kinder im stoff 5 bis 11 jährige weil
die frage uns auch im ministerium immer
wieder erreicht wenn ich das kurz
ergänzen ich habe genau die frage
vielleicht kann ich sie gerade vorlesen
zwar fragt michael kreutzfeldt das im
alter kreutzfeldt das in deutschland
soll die impfung aber also
voraussichtlich nächste woche werden ihn
immer dass wir zulassen in deutschland
soll die dem funk aber frühestens am 20
dezember beginn warum dauert das so
lange
danke das ist genau das worauf wir noch
mal hinweisen wollte zusagen
erwartungsmanagement wir gehen davon aus
stand jetzt wenn es keine
unvorhergesehenen erkenntnisse mehr bei
der immer gibt in der auswertung dass es
eben am 25 26 11 zu der
zulassungsentscheidung für den impfstoff
für 5 bis 11 jährige kommt wichtig ist
dass eine andere dosierung ist sind es
kann man sozusagen bei den 12 bis 17
jährigen konnten wir das auch einfach
mit den impfdosen den weils den
fläschchen machen die wir schon hatten
bei den fünf- bis elfjährigen ist das
eine andere produktion sind das andere
bei geringerer dosiert andere fläschchen
sozusagen die müssen aber erst
produziert und geliefert werden und alle
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
werden erst am 20 12 weil eben bei und
wegweiser erstmal produzieren muss
liefern muss weil station freigaben
braucht für jede einzelne produzierte
charge weil das im prozesse sind die
stattfinden müssen deswegen wenn alle
länder der europäischen union rund um
den stand heute immer wichtig dazu zu
sagen stand heute rund um den 20 12
dann die erste lieferung von
impfstoff für fünf bis elfjährige
bekommen wir gehen davon aus dass wir in
einer ersten lieferung gut zwei
millionen dosen dann bekommen werden wir
haben etwa viereinhalb millionen kinder
in dem alter 5 bis 11 so dass ich glaube
dass wir die erste nachfrage die es
geben wird dann auch mit dieser dosen
zahl sehr gut werden
beantworten können und ich will auch
jetzt schon im erwartungsmanagement
darauf hinweisen dass wir allen fünf bis
elfjährigen
diese impfung möglich machen wollen
stiko empfehlungen geben ich weiß nicht
wie die aussieht aber in dem moment wo
es einen zugelassenen impfstoff gibt
soll es genauso wie bei allen anderen
zugelassenen impfstoffen möglich sein
nach individueller entscheidung
und besprechung mit dem arzt der
natürlich dann auch bereit sein muss in
der abwägung zum impfen aber soll es
möglich sein das mg impft werden kann
und wenn dann noch eine empfehlung hinzu
tritt umso besser aber die möglichkeit
mit der zulassung werden wir geben so
wie wir sie auch bei den 12 bis 17
jährigen gegeben haben
übrigens ich glaube ich aber auch die
nachfrage von malte kreutzfeldt dürfen
kinder auch mit einer geringeren dosis
des erwachsenen im stoff geimpft werden
als es ist es ist eine geringere
dosierung deswegen gibt es ebenso zu
sagen ganz eigens produziert dafür auch
impfstoff aber einen extra produzierten
servicieren abgefüllt dann habe ich noch
mit bitte um kurze antworten noch mal
die kollegin police von ansa fragt viele
patienten werden derzeit generell
verlegt und wie viele nach italien
die genaue absolute zahl die kann ich
ihnen jetzt nicht nennen es sind ja auch
sind im moment bestimmt zwei drei mal
die woche unterschiedliche schalten
zwischen bund und landesvertretern stadt
sind ja auch viele beteiligt und noch
immer guten abstimmung
innenministerium mit dem lagezentrum
verteidigungsministerium auch wenn es um
verlegung geht das rote kreuz an der
rettungsorganisationen natürlich die
länder die kliniken die
intensivmediziner
wie hoch jetzt die absolute zahl ist
kann ich ihnen tatsächlich stante pede
nichts sagen wie auch die frage wie
viele jetzt in andere länder gehen das
ist immer auch natürlich teil der bund
länder abstimmung aber
federführend natürlich in diesen fragen
sind auch die länder
gleichzeitig wird sehr gewertschätzt
dass der bund eben da auch eine
koordinierende rolle hat boris
reitschuster fragt an sie herr spahn
fdp-vize kubicki sagt sich impfen zu
lassen sei keine frage der ist keine
frage der gesellschaftlichen solidarität
schon gar nicht sind menschen die sich
gegen eine impfung entscheiden für die
engpässe auf den intensivstationen
verantwortlich es ist vielmehr ausweis
staatlichen versagens zitat ende wie
stehen sie zu diesem vorwurf ich finde
die aussage hochproblematisch dazu sagen
wenn ich mein freiheitsverständnis
mein freiheitsverständnis bedeutet auch
verantwortung zu haben für den neben
sitzenden für die mitmenschen und in
freiheitsverständnis das sagt ich tue
was ich will und ob es auch andere für
andere folgen hat ist mir egal ist nicht
mein freiheitsverständnis
gut da habe ich halt eine
unterschiedliche freiheitsbegriff
vielleicht zu herrn kubicki aber das
halten wir einen der in der pluralen
gesellschaft auch aus ich glaube nicht
dass dieses freiheitsverständnis jeder
denkt nur an sich beim impfen uns
irgendwie weiter bringt schon gar nicht
in dieser pandemie sondern das impfen
ist eine entscheidung die man für sich
natürlich auch zuerst trifft um sich zu
schützen vor allem vorerkrankungen aber
es ist immer auch eine entscheidung die
andré mit betrifft und spätestens wenn
mir dann jemand sachen sparen geht es
jedoch nicht sagen ob ich mich impfen
lasse ich krank werde es doch meine
sache aber spätestens die pflegekraft
und der arzt sind dann irgendwie mit
betroffen sind nicht nur irgendwie ihre
sache ob sie krank werden oder nicht
betrifft immer auch andere so jetzt
fragen in unserem gesundheitswesen
natürlich nie warum jemand krank ist
wollen wir gar nicht anfangen wir
behandeln alle
aber dass man zumindest mal den gedanken
bei sich hat dass das was man da
entscheidet nicht nur einen selbst
betrifft
sondern im zweifel auch wie mit denen
man lebt im umfeld und vor allem auch
diejenigen die es betrifft wenn es
schiefgeht dafür werbe ich schon und ich
würde mir wünschen dass das auch von
allen oder vielen führenden
meinungsmachern im land auch ähnlich mit
mit eingeschätzt wird die wahrheit ist
einfach hätten wir eine deutlich
geringere zahl von ungeimpften
erwachsenen in deutschland wäre für alle
menschen in deutschland die lage jetzt
eine unterschiedliche da gibt es nichts
drumherum zu deuteln und ich finde in
einer solchen pandemie ist dass damit
auch eine frage von solidarität fragen
habe ich noch dann sind wir durch herr
kollege
ag die aktie von der niederländer
zeitung hd wird deutschland wie letztes
jahr auch niederländischer koma
patienten aufnehmen
in dem moment ich bin im guten engen
austausch mit meinem niederländischen
kollegen der junge wie wir auch
insgesamt in einem guten austausch sind
mit den niederländischen nachbarn auch
die bundesländer nordrhein westfalen und
niedersachsen ja auch ich komme selbst
aus der region wir haben patienten in
der region aus den niederlanden
aufgenommen und in dem moment wo die
allende uns bittet patienten aufzunehmen
und die kapazitäten dazu haben
werden wir natürlich auch die
niederlande unterstützen wie wir jedes
nachbarland unterstützen und wie wir
jetzt auch dankenswerterweise
offenkundig unterstützung bekommen von
nachbarländern insbesondere in den
regionen wo es gerade sehr sehr
schwierig ist denn natürlich macht es
mehr sinn wenn das geht einen patienten
aus baden württemberg nicht nach
schleswig holstein zu verlegen sondern
im zweifel in der region in der
nachbarschaftlichen das ist ja einfach
eine frage des aufwands und der
belastung die das übrigens auch für den
patienten macht wenn die strecken
entsprechend sind also kurz antwort ist
ja
das machen wir genauso wie
beim letzten mal und
dann die letzte frage die ich noch
online habe von susanna simon ska von
reuters die wirtschaftswoche berichtet
herr minister sparen wolle die kurve
pille von pfizer kaufen also ich vermute
sie meint das
bundesgesundheitsministerium ist das ist
das korrekt also es ist es ist korrekt
dass wir ihn habe ich aber glaube ich
und letzter woche hier schon gesagt dass
wir in gesprächen sind mit pfizer mit
ms.de übrigens auch mit allen anderen
aus 13 alle die
die sozusagen
erwartungsvolle und mit entsprechenden
daten unterliegt erwartungsvolle
medikamente haben sind wir natürlich im
gespräch wir haben die monoklonalen
antikörper gekauft weit vor der
zulassung sogar übrigens haben wir sie
auch gekauft in großem umfang an den
zeitpunkt als der impfstoff noch gar
nicht absehbar war ob er zugelassen wird
oder nicht weil das diese passive
immunisierung ein unterschied macht
wir haben im übrigen auch die
möglichkeit jetzt zum zum vorsorglichen
geben von monoklonalen antikörpern
gerade geschaffen durch eine änderung
der
der verordnung das heißt also in dem
moment wo sie in einem pflegeheim zum
beispiel ein ausbruch haben
können sie patientinnen können sie
bewohnerinnen und bewohner bei denen
noch nicht mal klar ist ob sie infiziert
sind oder nicht vorsorglich diese
monoklonalen antikörper geben das muss
sehr frühzeitig sein aber damit
erreichen sie einen guten schutz
das zeigen alle erfahrungen die wir
haben und wir haben gerade dabei die
verordnung so zu verändern dass man
sozusagen die nicht nur geben kann nach
einer festgestellten infektion sondern
prophylaktisch
eben auch schon vorsorglich da sind die
monoklonalen antikörper problem bei
denen ist es braucht eine infusion das
andere thema ist die frage der pillen
der tabletten die sind natürlich
leichter zu nehmen und ja kurz antwort
ist sie haben denn nicht der minister
sondern das bundesministerium für sie
nicht jeden sparen als privatperson
sondern es bundesministerium für
gesundheit ist in gesprächen und
verhandlungen mit diesen unternehmen um
natürlich auch für deutschland das
sicherzustellen dann sind wir durch mit
anfragen ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich
für die aufmerksamkeit herzlichen dank
für fossile danke ersparen
und damit schließlich die paar sekunden